Hello, and welcome to today's episode.
I am joined by Dmitry Kalining from VMware.
He is the maintainer of Carvel, an open
source tool chain for deploying to Kubernetes
and making our lives easier.
Hello, Dimitri. How are you?
Hey, David. Thanks for having me. I'm pretty
good. Awesome.
I I'm looking forward to this. Deploying to
Kubernetes is is far from an enjoyable experience
depending on the tools that we're using, and
I'm I'm hoping that you're gonna show me
some stuff today that's that's gonna change my
life for the better. Right? Hopefully.
Do you want to just then spend the
next minute? I mean, feel free to tell
us about Carvel and what problem it's trying
to solve and the different components that make
it up.
Sure. Sure.
Carvel started about a year ago.
It was actually known as k fourteen s
before.
We recently renamed it to Carvel.
It it started out as a few projects
that I was
working on
trying to improve what I
saw
as not a necessarily great experience deploying and
managing configuration for Kubernetes.
I think at the time, I was trying
to deploy
Knative to my cluster.
And,
you know, at the time, I think Knative
had a hard dependency on Istio.
And so I also had to install Istio,
and then, you know, Knative had about a
hundred different Kubernetes resources. So as you update
throughout,
you know, versions, it was kinda hard to
track what should be deleted, what should be
created, updated, etcetera. Right? Does
some of that stuff, but I just didn't
quite
feel like I had, you know, fine grained
control over that.
And then,
you know, as I was kind of playing
around and trying to deploy things to Kubernetes,
I've also
dealt with a, you know, several helm charts,
and I always found it to be quite
cumbersome to deal with textual templating. So
I ended up kind of digging in into
that area as well.
And so the first tool that came out
of all that was YTT.
This was the the the structural templating tool
for YAML.
The second tool, I believe, came out was
CAPP,
or I guess some people call it CAPP.
That's for deploying
configuration to Kubernetes and kind of managing it
over time.
And then there's actually a few few other
tools. They're probably less known than these two.
K build is probably the next one that
folks hear about. It kind of helps you
integrate your Docker building into
this Kubernetes
deployment workflow.
So, yeah, that was that was kind of
a small history of of Carvel.
Yeah. So when we when I said tooltune
earlier, I mean, it's definitely something instead of
tools that are trying to kind of improve
the developer experience across the entire lifetime of
a Kubernetes application, It's kind of the vibe
I was getting from all the different moving
parts and stuff like that.
Yeah. Well, one one of the key points
that I was
trying to
to explore is how do you actually have
this separate tools that do these distinct
things like deployment versus configuration management? How do
you keep the how do you keep them
separate but yet have them play
very well together? So kind of following the
Unix philosophy.
Yeah. That makes sense. Total sense. So let's
just pull up. I have
a website shared here.
And what we can see is that you
kinda broke this down into two sets of
tools. So we got, I guess, what are
the core tools on the top, and then
you've got some more experimental stuff, I guess,
that you're working on on the bottom.
That's right. So this is actually behind Carvel.
There's now a team at VMware. And after
various deliberations and whatnot, we decided to kind
of separate
this high level,
quite mature tools from something that we're experimenting
or, you know, messing around with.
Yeah. That makes sense.
So
today, we're gonna get hands on with these
tools, which I'm very happy about. But before
we do that, I guess,
would it be fair to say that these
tools directly compete with customized and helm and
just write in straight up YAML? Like, this
is this is a tool chain to replace
all of that from people's lives.
That's right. Yep.
Yep.
Okay. I'm definitely excited then. One of my
biggest think I ran out of it. That's
probably on a weekly basis on Twitter, But
just using Go templates inside of Helm charts
and fighting with wrangling YAML value files to
me is just is is quite cumbersome. And
I'm hoping that there are some of the
tools that we look at today can make
that a lot better.
Do you use Go templates language? Is that
a thing?
You mean outside of ITT?
Or
occasionally, you know, still have to deal with
various configurations here and there. Yeah. I I
I should probably just bake the bullet and
start learning it and get better at it
instead of complaining about it. But then what
would I what would I run about on
Twitter otherwise? So
That's why I gotta have some material.
Alright. So step one of every every episode
that I do here is how do I
install the tools? What is the the fact
to best definitive way for me to install
the Carvel toolchain?
You can scroll down
a little bit down to the page, and
there's a a few installation methods there.
Since these are separate
tools,
you know, you can either use a script
to install them all together,
or you can select individual tools from their
GitHub, download
releases
pages, or you can, you know, use Brew,
for example, if you're on Mac. Or actually,
Brew works on Linux, I found out. So
some someone someone wanted to use Brew on
Linux. So
it's
quite caught off guard there.
Yeah. I mean, I'm I've been I joined
I started a new possession recently with Packet,
and I got a Mac as part of
that role. And I'm still fighting against it.
I like, I am a Linux user and
trying to get myself accustomed to brew as
package manager. I mean, I come from Arch
Linux. I've got the AUR there, and it's
just everything in the world is packaged. Yep.
So I'm no stranger to Carvel Bash either,
but I will play it safe with the
brew tap.
At least then I'll get some more chats.
Hey. It's actually as you can see, the
the brew tap is still called k 14
s. We've been slowly
updating the names. Recently renamed the
Slack channel in our Kubernetes,
I guess,
in the Kubernetes Slack from k 14 s
to Carvel.
So what what inspired that name change then?
Inspired might be a
wrong name for that, but within VMware,
there is certain
naming guidelines.
And so this was one
of the one of the things that we
wanted to comply with and be friendly to
marketing and other folks within the organization.
Yeah. The the k fourteen s name was
just something that, me and my friend picked
as
a short thing to type.
But, you know, it was never meant to
be a kind of a top level marketing
name. Well, if the Internet is to be
believed, the k fourteen s is Kubernetes tools.
That is right.
We actually counted those letters, but then somebody
told us that you're not supposed to count
the space between Kubernetes and tools. So
at that point, we just said, you know
what?
K k 13 s would be unlucky. So
we went with k 14 s.
I like it. Alright. So now that my
brew is finished, this should mean, in theory,
if I could access the YTT.
Yeah.
K b l d. Oh,
k. Excellent.
I
guess now
and it would help if for once in
LA if I remember to start Docker before,
you know, the the call. But we'll give
that thirty seconds to get healthy, and I
should have a working Kubernetes cluster.
What what's the what's the choice over here
for how you run Kubernetes? Do you typically
use a
built in Docker built in Kubernetes and Docker
or something
else?
So I keep changing. I've been playing a
lot lately.
I've been battling with Kines running inside of
Docker for Mac, which works pretty well. I'm
also I really like MiniKube.
I just like the direction that they're going
in, and I've been trying to use that
with the new VMware fusion 12.
But Oh. Because it got the new player
release, which is like a week old or
whatever.
Mhmm. But it's free for personal use. So
now I can use that for hopefully a
slightly better experience.
Yeah. I'm a big fan of Minikube as
well just for the sake that it
comes with a Docker instance that you can,
you know, directly build and it's available to
the cluster.
Well, yeah, I have run into a few
problems running kind inside Docker Docker for Mac.
So
edge cases usually, but they
quite prominent.
Alright. So we've got the tools installed. I
am assuming now I have a cluster
I could spell.
That is my Docker from Mac cluster because
I see VPN kit and I've got oh,
I've got some cluster API stuff running, but
we'll just ignore that for now.
So
when we were chatting earlier, we're talking about
the direction that we wanted to play with
these tools. Now we could have jumped straight
into YTT, which is the the
templating side of the YAML aspect of it.
But you were also saying that it may
actually make more sense of trying to play
with key app first
to deploy a workload to our cluster.
So That's right. I think let's go with
that. How how do I use KeyApp, and
how do I deploy something to my cluster?
Well, I guess one way to
to look at CAP is that it's meant
to
track the resources that you're deploying to the
cluster. And the way it tracks it is
by applying a label, and then it associates
a name to it. So you should be
able to take any plain YAML out there,
maybe some kind of a Kubernetes example of
sorts somewhere,
and just use the deploy command under k
app
to to deploy it.
Okay. So one other thing, I maintain some
helm charts
for influx DB. I did template out some
YAML, which we can use with. But for
the sake of the key app stuff, what
I'm gonna say is let's just
keep it really simple for now
by NGINX with the most basic configuration I
can think of.
That will be okay for the demonstration purposes.
Yeah?
Should be. Should be.
So what you said there was I can
use key app, and it has some sort
of deploy sub command. Yeah. Yep.
And does that just work like my like,
the role that It's gonna be yeah. It's
gonna be dash f.
And but in addition to dash f, you'll
have to throw in dash a, which stands
for the name of the app.
I have to name my app. So I
can just call that NGINX?
Sounds good.
Yep. There it is.
So this is telling me that it has
to make some changes to my cluster. So
already, this is doing some sort of,
I don't know, preemptive reconciliation. It's looking at
what's in my cluster, looking at those labels
you mentioned, and trying to trying to work
out what changes are actually gonna happen.
Right. So it's so it
you know, I I believe most folks are
familiar with Terraform. Right? And within Terraform, there's
this idea of planning and then applying the
change set that it planned. Right? And so
we've done same exact thing in CAP where
we first
do a planning
session of what what's going to happen. And
as you can see over here, we have
a single resource, and the operation of it
is going to be create because CAP didn't
find that resource in the cluster.
And then it just presented you that plan.
So you can go ahead and apply the
plan.
And
CAP promises you that it's going to do
only what's in the plan. Right? So it's
not gonna go off and, like, change something
else. So you can be a % certain
whatever is shown to you. That's what's gonna
happen.
Alright. So I can see that it's created
my deployment as then
waiting
for changes. So it's actually observing the replica
sets in the pods being created?
That's right. Yep. We wanted to make it
a little bit more
friendly to finding out what's actually happening in
the cluster. A lot of times, right, you
just deploy a bunch of stuff and you
have no idea when it's done.
So CAP has some
effect to logic
for
checking out various resources and you know? So
this this case, I think it's deployment. Right?
So it knows how to wait for a
deployment based on the deployment status.
Okay. And, hopefully, it's useful information
to to know. You know, it looks like
the container was pending to be created, and
then eventually they're created.
So, I mean, the first thing that's jumping
right into my head now is that what
if I
break this
as what does Keyapt do? Like, let's say
I come in here and
and let's put those resource constraints back in.
Right? And if I set them far too
small
to the point where NGINX won't be able
to start, does that trigger anything with CAP?
It might. It depends what the
what the resource, I guess, is bubbling up
to its status. Right? So it depends if
the deployment is showing that kind of information.
CAP may also sometimes look it into the
associated resources, like the pods that are related
to the deployment
and raise some of their information, you know,
bubble up that to the user.
We actually recently
I think I had a
what was it? I
don't remember. There was there was actually a
request in improving some of this logic to
show this other
more rarely
seen condition pop up.
But it it depends. I mean, we can
check it out and see what happens.
Okay. So this is our first update. It's
now Yep.
Actually created the labels, and it's telling me
You can you can even do maybe if
you control c out of this and then
run the same command but with dash c,
you'll you'll see some, hopefully, diff over here
that shows you what's actually being changed.
That's nice. I like So that diff is
per resource.
Okay. I like that flag. Like, I actually
see in the the depth essentially before I
have to apply. It's pretty nice. Yep.
So it looks like NGINX is pretty happy.
Well, I saw I was I'm attached to
NGINX. In terms of it just didn't care.
So You may you may have to really
get this. I'm not even sure if that's
gonna
yeah. What if we pick a tag that
doesn't exist? Will that trigger some sort of
failures?
Yeah. I think so. I mean, there should
be somewhere somewhere image
pull.
Yeah. We should get an image from Microsoft.
So we can see that if again, which
I I really like that feature. That's pretty
nice.
And then we go. I see a four
zero four.
Yeah. So ending list.
Yep. So by by default, capital eight
until
so this is kinda interesting. Right? Because there's
no you know, Kubernetes is continuously reconsidering.
Right? Because maybe the the the engine x
44 is gonna show up in the next
five minutes. Right? Who knows? Right?
But
various resources, right, have defined their own rules,
like deployment, I think, as a a condition
that indicates that the deployment isn't progressing after
some time. Right? And you can actually tweak
it, I think, on the deployment. So CAP
follows those kinda
rules just by observing the status, but it
also has a global time out for fifteen
minutes, I think.
So if we see the air for fifteen
minutes, CAP will tell you that, you know,
nothing is really progressing.
It's probably time to give up. Obviously, that's
configurable, but
best case scenario is that you wanna be
actually changing
you wanna be changing the
your resources to have this tight feedback loop.
Right? The most common might be, like, adding
a readiness probe to your pod, right, such
that they don't just immediately become available. They,
you know, they they take their time to
start up properly.
Okay.
Well yeah. Let's not watch it for fifteen
minutes. So I just reverted
reverted that image change, apply that to my
cluster. I've now got I've got it just
kinda saying, yeah, we're good. If I run
that again,
it's just saying, hey. There's nothing to do.
It's in the walk, and we're good. Yeah.
Cool cool other command actually is cap and
stacked.
If you give it a dash a nginx,
you should be able to see,
you know, what's what's part of this app.
We might even see the old pod. Not
the old pod is already gone. But you
can actually see that Kubernetes
actually keeps
few replica sets. Right? And I think that
depends on, like, the history
parameter of a deployment or something like that.
I guess it's for fast rollback or something
like that. Yeah.
This kinda gives you a maybe a full
view of what's what's cap seeing under this
app.
Oh, yeah. I guess we've got a bit
of a contrived deployment right now, a very
basic engine x. There's not a lot going
on, but I can see how that inspect
passing in the app name
and getting back that list of resources that
have been deployed together.
I guess, in a real world or production
like scenario where I'm deploying a real microservice,
which maybe has a back end database, has
contact maps and secrets, like, this inspect view
is actually gonna be much more useful in
that scenario.
It's definitely I've I've actually learned quite a
bit
after
digging in on
what kind of various resources get created.
Like, you know, a lot of people know
about, like, kubectl get all,
but get all actually doesn't show you everything.
Right? It only shows you the things that
are tagged as all or whatever,
I guess, the proper term is not tagged
probably.
But there's there's quite a lot other, you
know, sets of resources. And so inspect actually
is
quite quite interesting to look at.
Yeah.
Awesome.
So is there anything else within KeyApp that
we should take a look at?
Well, it it kind of
the way to put it, there there's a
lot of kind of opinions
that I've baked into it working with area
various other systems before Kubernetes.
I I've been, I guess, in the
deployment and configuration game for some time, and
so Cap tries
to,
I guess, bake in a lot of interesting
features
that are helpful. For example, one of them
is
a lot of people run into a
challenge when a resource needs to change,
but Kubernetes doesn't allow you to change that
resource because,
I don't know, it's the field is immutable
or something like that. Right? And so from
a kind of a declarative perspective, right, how
do you actually deal with that? Right? Nobody
wants to be sitting there and doing all
kinds of manual changes to your cluster. Right?
So cap, for example, has special annotations
to control various behavior of what it what
it can do. So it it can say,
for example, if you see that the resource
is invalid
and you've marked off explicitly that resource this
resource is okay to recreate
for updates, then it will automatically do this
kinda work for you.
So, yeah, that is
you know, I guess as people start using
CAP in their environments, they they start, you
know, asking interesting question. Like, how do I
order, for example,
running a DB migration job before actually updating
the deployment, things like that? And so cap,
for example, as a feature for ordering
the the changes to be applied to a
cluster.
So, yeah, there there's there's a few interesting
sneaky, I guess, maybe features that
that are not
that you don't have to use, but you
can kind of opt into.
Okay.
So let's talk about this with a little
bit of a wider scope now then. Do
you see
CAP as a tool that people would use
to deploy
normal
Kubernetes manifest like we were doing? Or you
you probably see it in a way that
people should be having YTT
manifests
with cap deploying them as a resource. Does
that make sense? Or have I got that
wrong?
So the beauty of, I guess, embracing
this
you know, solving these problems in, you know,
in multiple tool, right, is that really it's
up to the user to decide what kind
of complexity
they need to tackle in their workflow. Right?
Some users, of course,
wanna be able to have configuration that could
be applied to multiple environments.
You know, it might be slightly different in
production.
They may decide to use customizer. Maybe they
decide to use YTT or maybe they're using
Helm charts or whatever it is. Right? And
so
the way I look at it, actually, I've
I've explicitly
said that it's
it's not,
I guess,
it's not something that we wanna constrain. Like,
this this tool is only for deploying,
I don't know, plain YAML or something. It's
it's really just tool deploying Kubernetes resources. And
if
if you happen to generate them from YTT,
great. If you happen to generate them through
a customized or Helm template or,
you know, I don't know, Pew or whatever
else. Right? Maybe even some JSON net tooling,
whatever.
Yeah. We we should be happy with that.
But, yeah, I I do see it as,
you know, I do see it as a
tool that the regular app developer can use
when they're deploying their own software that they've
written.
Or
they could be using it to deploy something
that the third party have, you know, provided
them, or it's something that maybe some of
the open source, you know, projects like strip
manager or whatever else is going on. Right?
So I see it as kind of a
scaling with your needs.
Okay. So that leads me on to two
different things then. I think just because
I'm a particularly curious person, what I'm gonna
do is
run this deploy because I wanna see what
happens when I point to add those
manifests
I generated earlier.
I just wanna see that preview
with slightly more going going on.
Okay.
So I can see the the r back,
the cluster rules, persistent volumes, and services.
Cool. I really do like that feature. That's,
you know, that's particularly useful.
Yeah. One one interesting thing actually that I
look at this diff is, you know, as
you can see there, there's a few cluster
resources
versus there's a few resources that go in
the namespace.
Their
cap cap doesn't really make a difference between
a resource that's namespaced versus a cluster level
one.
You know, it doesn't really care if it's
a CRD or not. It'll just be managing
it in the same exact way. So there
there's that benefit to just having a, you
know, same behavior applied to all of these
resources.
Alright. Cool.
So one more thing on CAP then.
When we were on the website, there was
a controller
for CAP.
Do you wanna That's right. Put a bit
of insight in that? Is that something that
runs in the cluster
at a GetOps fashion or something else? Yep.
Yep.
So the idea there is
if you
There we go. If
you
think about what most people are doing, right,
there's some kind of a
fetching of configuration going on. Right? There is
some kind of a mangling, like templating or,
I don't know, overlaying or whatever going on.
And, ultimately, there's, you know, the last step
deploy. Right? And so we've we've decided to
codify that workflow
in a CRD.
And so you get to specify a app
CR.
Actually, if you scroll up here, there's the
examples folder over here. Yep. There might be
some
some of them might be a little like,
maybe Concourse Helm or something or NGINX Helm.
Yeah. Yeah. NGINX Helm. Let's take a look
at that.
So,
yeah, AppCR effectively
split that up into these three sections, fetch
template and then deploy. Deploy, obviously, is happening
with CAP.
Fetching and templating are actually
they're decoupled steps, and there's various strategies like,
you know, fetch it from Git, fetch it
from your Docker
registry.
So we we also are believers of putting
configuration
into Docker images. That way, all your assets
are together.
Or or maybe it's fetch a Helm chart.
Right? And then the templating step could be
also separate. So for example, in this case,
we're we're using Helm template to template the
the Bitnami NGINX, but we're also using YTT
on top of that to change
how
the the service is configured for NGINX.
And then, ultimately, we do a deploy at
the end of that. So it it kind
of it's a it's a opinionated way
to do, you know, your your deploys to
the cluster. And because it's a controller, it
keeps on doing them. Right? So you can
decide whether you wanna float kind of on
the latest reference or where you wanna look
it down to a particular thing.
So, yeah, that that's a
it's a controller that's meant to represent the
that 95%
case.
K. Cool.
Let's pop back. Actually, may maybe one thing
to note is
more
after after kind of building up the controller,
I figured, well,
you know, you can use all these tools
locally yourself, right, to kind of replicate
that workflow if you wanna debug, for example,
if you just wanna iterate on it quickly.
But I was also thinking making a CLI
that's effectively the same thing that the cap
controller does. Right? Maybe literally even the same
code. Right? But just happens to run locally
where you can have a maybe, like, run
it once kind of a thing. So kind
of a an interesting idea of making it
more,
I guess,
localized when you're developing stuff?
Yes. There is one of my colleagues, Jason.
Sorry.
He's actually working on a proof of concept
right now of a local binary that emulates
Kubernetes
API server without having any API server. So
I'll drop you that link. It may be
something interesting for you. Yeah. I think I've
seen it actually on Twitter. This this in
in our case, I think we actually don't
need Kubernetes. We just need that inner loop
that does the reconciliation,
so it wouldn't have to fetch any resources.
But I I I see what you're getting
at. I think there's a there's a lot
of things that could it
well, I mean, we want the Kubernetes API
because it it's nice and declarative, but we
don't necessarily need to cluster. We just need
a daemon that could run locally or be
run once. I think there's a a good
market for applications there.
Alright. Let's let's move on over then to
this templating thing. We've got YTT here. So
I understand key app now. That makes perfect
sense to me. I like the functionality that
that brings to the table.
The key app controller, think, is really sweet.
I'm looking forward to playing with that at
some point where I can, you know, have
that running inside my cluster.
Now I wanna get rid of
of Helm or at least the template a
bit or the customized a bit. And this
is where my ITT slots right in. Yeah.
Yep. That's right. Templating and overlaying.
That's the that's the goal for this tool.
And and
templating, we're we're talking about the exact same
thing that Helm does. And when we talk
about overlays, we're talking about modifying or tweaking
those generated templates per environment. Right?
Yeah. So it's
I've over the years, I guess, I've
come to a conclusion.
I don't know if people agree with that
conclusion or not, but I I think
you you have to use templating and overlaying
together
to to cover the use cases that you
have. Right? Because we've seen that if you
don't have the overlaying,
then a lot of people as Helm chart,
let's say, gets more mature. A lot of
people keep on asking, like, well, let's add
one more configuration now between values. Right? And
so you end up with a thousand values
there.
And, you know, those values are probably used
by like, each one is used by one
person only.
And so,
really, I think, you know, 95%
cases that are common between people should be
something like, you know, values, should be just
templated by the author.
There's no, you know, crazy direction that they
need to deal with. It's just right there
inside inside the template.
But there's, let's say, a 5% case where
an end user
wants to actually, you know, modify something. Right?
There's no way that they have this data
values because it's not a common thing to
modify. Maybe it's very specific to their cluster.
Maybe it's specific to their environment, whatever it
is. And so having a single tool that
has the consistent
kind of a methodology
for both of those
approaches,
in my mind,
I think, is is
actually advantageous.
So, yeah, YTT tries to do both.
Okay. Excellent. I mean, that thing you just
mentioned there about
adding one new thing to the values dot
YAML, and it's probably consumed by one person.
It's definitely a problem that I face with
with the influx DB in the Telegraph helm
charts, particularly Telegraph.
Because every time Influx add a new plug
in to Telegraph, someone comes along with a
pull request, adds a new values format to
enable that plug in for their deployment, and
there's over 200 plug ins.
And you end up in a really unreally
hellhole,
you know, I'm just gonna call it a
hellhole, where you have to try and convert
YAML to TOML for the Telegraph configuration.
Mhmm. And it's nothing but painful. So let's
see what we can do here then.
Now what's the best way for us to
kinda play with this? Did we just
start writing some
So there is a there is a playground
here
that's interactive.
It just kinda gives you a feel for
what the tool does.
Actually,
quite a few people have have really liked
the playground. So that was a good call
on my friend's
part on making that a priority.
That's.
He works now at, I think, AWS.
But, yeah, the the playground is a good
way to start, kind of learn. There's a
few examples there if you
if you scroll up just a little bit.
Yeah. If you you think that you wanna
kind of take maybe some YAML and try
to
make it maybe
template a little bit. That could be a
good start.
Okay. So let me
let me throw a question at you first
then. It's like assuming
I am an application developer that's already deploying
stuff to Kubernetes.
So it's just basic
YAML manifest right now.
Is the approach to adopt to my ITT
to incrementally
swap bets in and out of that or
to just rewrite everything as YTT?
It's a great question.
Yeah. One one of the one of the
interesting side effects of being
a templating tool that really deals with structures,
right, and more specifically, YAML,
is that really a a YAML file
is a valid YTT template.
It's you know, YTT just reads it in
and spits out the same exact thing. Right?
There was no, let's say, variable substitutions or
anything like that.
The the simplest thing, you know, to kind
of level
up, let's say, there is some kind of
value that you wanna insert. Maybe it's different
for two different environments. Right?
The the simplest thing is just literally throw
in,
you know, one little usage of YTT within
that YAML.
And, you know, it might be one line
or two lines,
and
that that's how you really get started. So,
yeah, the the intent is definitely not to
change any of your YAML configuration. It's more
just start out and just add
some of these directives
over time if if you need to. Yeah.
Then what I would suggest is,
I mean, right now, I could run y
t t against this engine next dot YAML,
and you're saying I'll just get the same
YAML back. That that Should be. Yep. Yep.
So digest the dash f again like this?
Yep.
That's right.
Yep. Okay. So let's then tackle the first
one of my many annoyances with Kubernetes channel
is the duplication between the selector and the
labels. Is that something we can then template
out with YTT so we only define it
once? Yep. Absolutely.
So
YTT
because it's dealing with structures. Right? And, you
know, as we can see on line twelve
and eight, right, we we have a
single map item. Right? A map. Right? So
we can pull that map out into a
function and just call the function from two
different places.
And all that really requires is,
you know, cutting out the app NGINX and
moving it up to the top level of
the document and
wrapping it in a in a depth.
So
you might this this probably referring yeah. Exactly.
Referring to an example is a little easier
to explain there
or to show at least.
The the key there is that YTT directives
are all YAML comments, so they just leave
along the the YAML nodes.
And
everything that's prefixed with, you know, pound at,
it's
it's annotation, what we call, is in YTT.
And
these annotations, in fact, could tell YTT
where certain things are kind of a like,
this is a definition of a function or
this is a four loop, let's say, or
this is whatever it is. Right? So we're
using a Pythonic language
called Starlark from Google. Great language. Great library
to use.
And it's actually
the YAML gets converted,
you know,
at runtime to to a template that's fully
written in Starlark, and then Starlark gets executed,
and you get the output back.
So, yeah, if you grab, like, line three
from from this example over here
and just drop it in before. Yep. And
then we also will close it. Yep.
There you go. So now we have a
function. And all it takes now is to
call that function from multiple places.
And so to call it would be if
you go to line 11. Actually, if you
so if if you write it out right
here
yeah. So if you do pound at labels
yeah. So
what's what's happening here is actually it's not
gonna quite work because
we don't know if you mean that the
value of much labels should be the result
of the labels function. It could just be
calling a function in the middle of the
YAML. And so if you drop it on
the same line
as much labels,
then YTT is going to know that, hey.
You're actually calling a function.
And, also, you'll have to throw in the
two parentheses at the end of that as
a kind of a regular function call.
Alright. Okay. Gotcha. Yep.
Alright. Is there a way to keep my
editor happy, or is that always just gonna
moo and at me whenever Yeah. I'm not
quite sure. Is this Versus Code? Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not quite sure what it's complaining
about right now. We we do have a
Versus Code plugin
that we've recently
started out and, you know, we'll we'll probably
iterate on. Yeah. I'm not sure if
what exactly it's not happy about, but oh,
yeah. I guess it's value. So, I mean,
if I drop this n, will will YTT
then
replace that value, or is it gonna YTT
is actually not gonna be quite happy with
providing the static value and the value that's
gonna get generated to YTT and mostly
because
it it might be just confusing to users,
like, what what what's happening over here, and
so we wanted to prevent that. We may
open that up later. Not quite sure. We're
we're trying to be as strict as possible
today in terms of the rules, and so
we can always loosen up.
But, yeah, today, YTT is gonna complain at
you saying that's not allowed.
Okay. So let's let's do that. I I
I like to see things work. So
I can see those labels being injected.
You're saying that's just gonna tell me no.
Yeah. Yep.
So it's saying it's best to jam on
node to either have, like, computed or blah
blah blah.
Because it's got both. Right? Okay. That's right.
Okay.
So I will Yeah. And, of course, now
that we have this function, right, we can
call as many times as you want. So,
like, on line 14, you could also call
it.
Should be all happy.
Right. Nice.
Okay. That makes sense to me. So
we're using
Starlack language to define functions.
We're going down the comment approach
so that the YAML can still be read
by other YAML files, I guess, or set
back highlight works.
The it this is kind of an
interesting world. Right? Just because the template is
YAML,
you do get some benefits from other tools.
Right? But for example, lot of tools, they
strip out comments, right, because they're just not
aware that, hey. I should keep the comments,
which
over time, I guess, that may get fixed
through improvements in YAML libraries, like the
Go YAML v three.
But, yeah, the
main motivation for
making the template in YAML itself
was specifically for
being able to read the YAML structure and
then overlay the metadata on top of that.
YTT Lint is actually one of the there
was a there was a person from SAP.
He was experimenting
with how to
do some
type checking inside this kind of a world.
Versus CodeYTT is
from
Eli.
He that was his experiment and kind of
improving
that.
But, yeah, we've we've we've got some work
to do there.
Well, I mean, I've installed that that Lint
one, and right away, my little red squiggle
of death has gone away. So I'm pretty
happy.
Fair enough.
Alright. Cool. So
something that jumped out at me and the
the playground example here. What is this load
statement at the top? I couldn't really work
that out right away.
So
in Helm, I believe you can just say,
like, dot values
dot something. Right? It's kinda like the
values is globally available.
We've tried in YTT templates to be very
explicit about where things come from. So for
example, if you wanted to move a function
into a separate file, right, the the the
labels function that's been written,
you would have to do an explicit load
of that file to grab that function. Right?
So explicit export
explicit imports of of whatever variables or functions
that you care about.
Same applies to the built in YTT modules.
So YTT comes with various modules like
data one is to
get the
the data values that the user has provided
to us.
There's, you know, various ones like base 64
to encode or decode things. Maybe there's a,
for example, overlay
functionality in YTT is actually implemented as a
module so you can programmatically do some overlaying
yourself.
So, yeah, there there's various there's various modules
that it includes.
And so here, we're saying, please import the
data module. And under data module, there's data
dot values, which allows you to use what
the user
has provided to us.
Okay.
That makes sense to me.
So the next thing then I think that
makes sense for this example
would
be
I'm thinking of the helm.
What are we doing now? I so I
would be able to define things globally that
could be applied in in multiple templates. Is
there a way to do that with YCP?
Yes. When when you say globally, do you
mean like a same function or something like
that? Or
Oh, yes. So if I,
you know, say this was across two files
and I've got a service dot YAML I
don't necessarily want to define the labels in
each. Got it. Yep. Makes sense. Yep. So
yeah. So at this point, you would say
so you would have a service dot YAML
that has that service,
and
we would create actually a separate file called
the maybe, I don't know,
deployment dot lib dot yaml.
And that's where we'll put our function so
that we can import it from both places.
Okay. So I can just let's I'll call
it a b c dot yaml. That's
alright. Yeah. One thing, you do have to
call it
dot lib dot yaml as the extension. So
for now, we'll put that restriction to avoid
kind of a people importing
templates themselves from other templates.
And so everything that's, you know, labeled as
in dot YAML is importable by the regular
templates.
Okay. So I have my dot lab dot
YAML, and you're saying I can just Yep.
This function over there? That's right.
And then I can send that function
from here first. Because right now, I've got
my my y t t lens. It's kicked
in and went, hey. This this doesn't exist.
So Yep.
So, yeah, you would use a pound at
at the top, then space, and then type
in load.
And then you would open parenthesis.
Maybe it's, like, double quotes at y t
t.
Or actually, no. No. At y t. Yeah.
It's a b c dot a b yamo,
I bet.
Yep. And then the second argument would be
the name of the function.
So it's gonna be a string as well.
Yep. So that should make the labels available.
Yeah. I'm not quite sure
if YTT Lint has been
I I think it's been used
for a long or it's been experimented
a long time ago, so it may not
know certain things.
But, yeah, the this this should be okay.
Okay. So this based on this syntax here,
if I had
10 different functions inside of my library, YAML,
would they all need to import it individually?
Is there a way to just bring in
everything?
So it's kinda interesting. The Starlark language defines
this so load is actually not a not
a function, but it's a special, I guess,
keyword or directive.
And it does require you to specify all
of the symbols that it imports.
However, the the trick here is that if
you're a b c lib yaml has
lots of functions,
you could actually
create a little structure that holds them all.
And all you gotta do is import the
little structure over here.
So it may be, like, structure a little
a b c, and then you would say
a b c dot labels.
So it's actually kind of bundling it up
into a little object, and then you just
import
the the little object altogether.
We actually
consider adding
a different
way of doing a load to kind of
be more
closer to what,
I believe, JavaScript folks do when they just
assign a return of the load to a
variable and just user of that.
Might be might be a little bit more
friendlier, I guess.
So just to kind of elaborate on what
you said there. I mean,
were you suggesting that I would do something
like this?
No. No. So you would still keep the
you would still keep the labels. So we
we are importing a symbol on line one,
the label's name. So you wouldn't wanna be
changing the YAML itself. So let let's just
say that you have a second function over
here. Maybe you can copy it and have
two of them now here.
Yeah. So now we've actually have two symbols,
labels and labels too that you have to
export. Right? And so instead of
instead of the user on the other side
importing them manually kinda one by one, you
can create this thing called a struct.
So it's effectively a
better looking map, if you will. So I
don't remember if we have an example of
that.
But, actually, we might have an example
in the YTT repo because I believe someone
was asking about this. Might be in the
docs somewhere.
Let me see if I can find it
real quick.
Load.
Oh, yeah. There it is.
So I'll send you a link over here
real quick.
If you scroll down just a little bit,
keep on scrolling down. So there you go.
So it says right under your cursor, it
says to load the cell functions from a
single file, you can do effectively that. So
what what that allows you to do is
just make a little object that has two
fields, you know, label and label as one.
So right now, it's little verbose, I would
say. Definitely wanna improve on that, but that
would be one way to go about it.
Alright. Okay.
So I guess
random stuff just keeps popping up in my
head now. Do
I need to define this as YAML, or
can I use dot star to then, you
know, get some text highlighted and other things
from my function?
So
it's an interesting kind of a choice to
make. Right? So when you're writing templates,
you might be dealing with functions that return
a bunch of structures. Right? To me, let's
say, you're defining a structure, it's way easier
to just, you know, maybe write it in
YAML or copy paste it from somewhere that's
already in YAML. Right?
And so a lot of times, I will
say, since you're dealing with YAML, I would
just stick with Lib YAML. Right? Now if
you're writing maybe functions that are more,
I don't know,
compute
related,
like, maybe you're, like, I don't know, multiplying
things and adding things and maybe, I don't
know, appending strings or whatever it is. Right?
You might actually not be using a lot
of the YAML structures at all. Right? So
at that point, I would say it makes
sense to, let's say, it in the dot
star file, and then, you know, it is
the same exact kind of load directive from
the other side. In this case, I guess,
the example that's have it as is the
star file where you just have, you know,
returning two integers for whatever reason. But, yeah,
it's really up to the to the end
user to decide if they're dealing with YAML
and stick with LibyaML. If they're not, then
star is also fine.
And I'm assuming because this is, a I
think it's a subset of Python. I would
just return a a Python deduction right here,
and that would return me something that looks
like YAML? You you could you could definitely
do that. Yep. So dictionaries will be converted
to the regular YAML maps.
Actually, since since since we mentioned this, there
is another type of templates that YTT can
deal with is textual templates since in you
know, when you deal with Kubernetes, sometimes you
have to actually do some textual templating,
which maybe, I don't know, for whatever reasons,
is more appropriate for,
you know, whatever you're doing. And so you
could actually have a lead dot TXT,
right, that
has a function that's really doing some kind
of a nice textual formatting. Right?
And so that's kind of another
another,
I guess, consideration to make when writing those
templates.
Okay.
There's a lot going on here. Like, I
think there's a lot of options. But what
you're saying there, quite a succinctly, was just
stick to the LabiAML approach. Use use that
until you need to break out for something
that's a bit more complicated or fits a
different purpose. That's right. Okay. Cool.
I will stick with the YAML.
Okay. We're back.
So let's we have we have kind of
looked at the functions. We've imported the functions.
I mean, that all works pretty self explanatory.
What about now if I wanna tweak this
NGINX deployment for a stage in our production
deployment and their number of replicas is gonna
change? So let's
set replicas
to 100
Mhmm. Which I don't I only wanna prod.
So how do I go about overlaying this
to make this tweakable?
So if we do wanna use overlay,
we would actually have a separate file.
It could be, like, overlay dot YAML or
replicas dot YAML.
Okay.
Overlay dot YAML. Mhmm.
And
the tricky, right, is that
the world of overlay, at least in my
mind, is split into
two kind of steps.
Right? One step is to find
what you're trying to overlay on top. And
second step is what the operation you wanna
do once you found it. Right? So for
example,
we wanna find
a particular resource,
a deployment in our example. Right?
And we also wanna find spec dot replicas,
and then
then we wanna replace the value of it.
Right?
So it might be a little easier to
copy from one of the examples. Let's see
if we got a
overlay example. I believe we do.
So, actually, let's
see if we got it.
There's
overlay files. Yeah. Okay. Overlay files. Example 16
might be what you're looking for.
So here,
the overlay is, I guess, in there's actually
two overlays here. One is an ops one
YAML, and one is an ops two YAML.
So we can probably grab the entire thing
in ops one YAML and just modify
it to our need.
So on line one, right, we see that
we're loading in the overlay library.
That's not always necessary, but in this case,
because we're using an overlay module functionality on
line three, that's that's why it's needed there.
And then on line three,
we're saying, let's find
something that has metadata name example
ingress one. Right?
So in our case, we probably wanna be
doing some other finding. Right? Like, what are
we actually looking for?
So I guess we could do metadata
labels.
You might have to wrap it in in
another set of hash then for the app.
Right? Yeah.
So and then this was app engine x.
Yeah. Like, there's something like that. Right? That's
right. In fact, we could've even used our
function over here if we really wanted to,
right,
for the
labels
to to get the same label in here.
A lot of times I've seen people actually
do
is use the kind and the name of
the object to kind of identify it uniquely
enough within their configuration, but this this will
also do. So overlay subset just tries to
find whatever is kind of a shared.
Confirm So and then so yeah. So once
we found this object so by default,
we are we're going to or by default,
YTT overlay functionality expects that it's going to
find one object. So in some in forever
whatever reason, we don't have that one copy
of that object that matches this subset, then
it's going to tell us, hey. Hold on.
Something is wrong.
And then so instead of the whole metadata
annotations
removal,
we'll we'll be just doing spec replicas. Right?
Yep.
That's right. That's all there is to it.
Okay. So there's something I wanna confirm there.
What I think you suggested was I could
use the labels function here.
That's right. Yep. And so I would just
have to copy the import
Yep.
Into my overlay.
So
did I mess that up?
Yeah. I'm There's one more. Yep. There's one
more missing there. There you go. K. So
from the command line now,
how do I piece this together?
So there's an interesting property of YTT is
that it doesn't allow any kind of so
the the
the execution environment is very self, you know,
contained. Right? There's no way to access time.
There's no way to access file system, no
network, no nothing. Right? And so because we're
doing all these loads, we actually have to
give the files to YTT that we're trying
to load. So in this case, it would
be like YTT dash f nginx dash f
overlay dash f a b c lib yavl.
Yep.
Alright. So
That that error you said was gonna happen
if we didn't get a match.
It says it it's a number of match
notes to be one, but was zero. Ah,
you know what?
That is true. Yeah. The labels that we're
actually trying to find is not inside the
metadata. Right?
It's elsewhere
because we didn't
we didn't have anything. Yeah. Well, let's just
make that work. Right?
Yeah. Why not?
Don't I I guess it is better. Yeah.
This this is actually one of the kind
of a one of the
goes back to the idea of being as
strict as possible. Right? Because you wanna find
those error message errors as
at your configuration time, not at the time
when you're deploying and things are not working.
Right?
Oh, yeah. Definitely. I think that's a good
thing for it to catch. And the alternative
to me, hovering that together there,
would just be to update the overlay and
spec
selector
and then
match labels.
That's right. That would be an option. Yep.
Think you have to throw in one more.
Yep.
Spec, selector, match labels
rather than just throw in new labels into
our metadata.
That worked. Nice. And then we have our
replicas of one.
So from a a, I guess,
some sort of deployment pipeline where I was
piecing this together, my environment my deployment pipeline
would have to be environment aware that it
could just fill in the correct overlay, and
it's just gonna work. That's right. Yep.
And a lot of times, we actually
we we see folks which instead of using
individual files, they just use directories. Right? So
you can have a config directory that contains
NGINX, YAML, and a b c lib YAML.
And then they may also have, like, a
production directory that contains whatever overlays you need
to contain. Right? So you're not really concerned
about,
you know, which files are individually included. Right?
You're just relying on,
you know, the file system to tell you
what's what.
K. So you're saying I can move this
into a deploy directory.
I need my library here.
Okay. So my command could then You you
you you do wanna move the library into
the deploy as well since it's
since it's being imported by NGINX YAML directly.
It's also being imported by our overlay.
Does that mean I have to put the
path here like this? So,
actually, no. Yeah. The the this should work.
You just have to remember yeah. You just
have to remember to include it through dash
f. Yeah.
Right. Okay. So the first thing I would
do is to include any libraries that I
need. I could then specify my deploy directory
followed by my overlay directory.
Yep.
I guess, and this still works. Okay.
Yeah. It's it's the
what's interesting is that,
you know, I've previously been involved in various
tooling that was always very strict. And so
this time, I've I've tried to
make
it just kind of a little less opinionated
in terms of how you integrate with your
workflows and Unix environment and whatnot. Because a
lot of people out there, they're all doing
all kinds of DIY
installations
of of Kubernetes cluster, and they have their
own opinionated workflows. Right? So we wanna cater
to that. Right? If you really wanna kind
of separate them, you know, may maybe you
have 10 different ways of how you overlay
things. Maybe it's like dev and then, like,
dev extra and whatever else. Like, it's kind
of up to you how you manage the
files.
There are benefits and downsides to that approach.
Right?
Yeah. Definitely.
And but I could I I'm really starting
to get a good patron of of how
these tools come together, how they work together,
and the kinda responsibilities
for each, It's I think it's starting to
make them look very, very interesting.
So we're kind of approaching an hour now.
So what I would like to say is,
like,
we can definitely demo anything else that you
think is important for people to see, or
maybe we could just do a quick
few minute recap of the other tools and
what their responsibilities are. And then I will
thank you and say this has been really
cool.
So
do you wanna show off KeyBuild, or should
we just quickly talk about KeyBuild, Image Pack,
and vendor?
I think we can talk about them. I
think if folks are, you know, interested to
look in, you know, it's it's there. They
can also, you know, jump in our Slack
channel, ask any any questions. We're very responsive
there.
So I guess so k build is
is trying to solve well, it started out
as solving one particular problem. Right? So we
actually have this problem right now. Right? We're
just using image NGINX. Right? And so we
never know what's gonna deploy. Right? Because NGINX
latest will keep on moving. Right?
And so what KBill does, maybe we can
actually showcase that real quick,
is if we pipe the YTT output into
into cap. Right?
Right now, it just gonna say, let the
cluster try to find the latest thing. Right?
But cable actually finds the image references within
your files
and switches them from
non
digest
URLs to the digest reference URLs.
And
what that ultimately gets you, right, is that
that immutability
of the config. Right? So let's say if
your deployment has been running for a long
time in your cluster and for whatever reason,
some of the NGINX pods need to restart.
Right? There's not gonna be a chance that
when the pods do restart, they pick up
an entirely different version of NGINX since the
time you've deployed it in the first place.
Right?
So by using this digest URLs everywhere where
k build finds the image reference,
you're kinda locking everything down.
And on top of that, you know, kind
of the second step to that was, well,
when you're developing locally, you actually may want
to get,
you know, run your Docker build process, right,
in the middle of all that. Right? You
have your configuration. You made some changes to
your app.
So you wanna run the Docker build, and
then you wanna do a cap deploy.
And so that's, of course,
cumbersome for you to do. So k build
with a little bit of configuration will actually
go ahead and run the Docker build for
you and replace
the image reference with whatever got built.
Right? So k build is really, I guess,
focusing on how do you integrate into your
deployment,
you know, pipeline
this image
finding and and building.
Today, can use, like, Docker build and pack
build. So that's the build packs folks.
Okay. That makes sense. I I I think
what it I think what a lot of
people don't realize is that when you deploy
something to Kubernetes and you're using an an
image tag rather than content addressable shares,
is the if that pod or that deployment
runs on multiple nodes and that tag changes
at some sort of random time, you could
actually end up with two different versions of
that image across your cluster or more depending
on if a pod crashes, it's rescheduled on
to another another week later and pulls in
that that tag, which has been overwritten.
I see it so many times where people
end up with this completely weird cluster configuration
with different versions of their image.
Right. Right. That idea of key build resolving
those at deployment time and then pushing that
to the cluster.
Yep.
That's
yeah. That's that's that's kind of how I
end up with that,
you know, separation of the concerns because you
you do want it to make it pluggable
for all the other folks out there, right,
that let's say, use customized or or helm
template or whatever it is. Right?
And so kind of a cousin of k
build is image package. We're actually moving some
of the functionality of k build into image
package right now. The functionality that I'm talking
about is
ability to take a set of images and
move them to your private registry.
A lot of people call it relocation.
So image package
kind of combines the concept of
you wanna keep your configuration in a Docker
registry
right next to your images. Right? So for
example, if you decided to say
InfluxDB
version 1.1
is ready, you just push it up to
the registry. And now it's under, I don't
know, apps slash influx DB configuration or something
like that.
But influx DB configuration is also referencing, like,
10 other images probably.
And
when you, let's say, dealing with a environment
that needs to be all firewalled away from
public Internet, Right? You wanna take all of
that configuration and move it into their, you
know, registry.
And so image package allows you to do
that. Well, right now, it's not quite there
yet. We're actually like I said, we're moving
that functionality from k build.
But image package
introduces this concept of a bundle where it's
a image configure it's a application configuration plus
a set of images that it references. We
kinda see it as one thing.
And so
that
that kind of
allows you to to manage your environment more
confidently in terms of where this you know,
where the configuration is coming from, where the
images are coming from.
Excellent.
This all sends
really cool. It's pretty much a tool to
make all of my Kubernetes painful experiences that
little bit better. So
it's great that these are all being worked
on.
So
I think we've covered an awful lot today,
and, you know, there's obviously so much more
that people can pick up. So what I
would recommend is there was a talk at
KubeCon a few weeks ago. Is that correct?
That's right. Yep. Check that out. There is
the Carvel channel on the Kubernetes Slack,
there's obviously the get repositories as well. There's
plenty of examples for people to go and
start the experiment on their own and understand
how the Carvel tools can help them.
Is there anything you would like to add
to that before we finish up, Dimitri?
Thank you for having me. It's been it's
been pretty fun. You know, I really like
the the format that you have going on.
Yeah. No. That's
pretty much it. We welcome anybody in our
Slack channel to chat about various problems that
they may have.
And if it happens, then we can help.
That's that's even better. Alright. Awesome. Well, thank
you very much for joining me and taking
the time out of your day to kind
of show me the tools and walk me
through it step by step. It's really helped
me have a better understanding and and hopefully,
the people that are watching on YouTube as
well. So thank you. Have a great day,
and I'll speak to speak to you soon.
You too. Bye bye.